from stuffed unicorn in jokes to secret
witcher game references season two is
loaded with hidden details you might
have missed the first time around
yipikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video i'm revealing all the very best
easter eggs and callbacks in the second
season of the witcher spoilers ahead of
course so take care
when jennifer meets siri in the sixth
episode after the young princess
stumbles in on hair and geralt kissing
the way he introduces them is a little
easter egg for book readers siri i'm
sorry this is my
dear friend this is a nod to the letter
geralt wrote tien in the books after
they've been separated for a long time
and how he awkwardly addressed her as
dear friend dear friend later on siri
asks yennefer about unicorns and whether
they really exist to which yen replies i
used to own a stuffed one until it broke
under mysterious circumstances that's a
cheeky reference to both the witcher 3
game and the sword of destiny book
notice in the show how yen looks at
geralt after she replies he gives her a
half smile then she smiles knowingly to
herself siri's follow-up that she'd like
to meet a unicorn herself one day is a
reference to how unicorns really do
exist in the witcher universe and a hint
at how in the book she meets and
befriends one called little horse which
she also uses to jump between worlds in
the middle of the great hall at care
morin is a medallion tree and after
escull dies thessamir adds his medallion
to the many others there which serve as
a memorial to the fallen witchers in
this close-up shot we can see various
styles of medallion but this particular
design here is an easter egg to the
witcher game another interesting detail
on the reverse of eskel's medallion
which we can also see on geralt's
costume is an intricate spiral of
symbols these appear to be inspired by
the real life festos disc whose meaning
has been hotly debated by scholars for
decades though one interpretation is
that the symbols are a minoan prayer to
the mother goddess
the netflix show isn't afraid to get a
little messed several times this season
for instance when yasukiya meets someone
who comments on one of the bard's songs
it's a bit complicated it took me to the
fourth verse to understand their
different timelines that's a nod to the
somewhat confusing nature of the show's
first season and it's three separate
timelines which eventually converged
that magic kiss that was a bit cheap
there he's referencing geralt and
jennifer's mid-battle kiss in the dragon
cave that was geralt using yen's magic
to strengthen his aardblast but it was
also mocked by some fans as being cheesy
and a little cringy i spotted the dragon
reveal a mile away oh you're clever
that's the twist that botch who hired
geralt for the dragon hunt was actually
a golden dragon himself
although there's no geralt bath scene in
season two to continue the meme from the
game we still get the running joke about
how badly he smells you can bathe in the
next room you recovered horse yarpin
uses a unique looking weapon with a
metal hand during his attacks this
season and the show's armory department
created an equally intriguing backstory
for it which features yarpan cutting the
hand off a nilfgaardian sentry after a
disagreement then getting it cast in
bronze and notice that in a similar vein
two of the other dwarves in his crew
have weapons with a metal foot on the
end when the deathless mother took siri
away in a fantasy world we get a replay
of events in sintra from the first
season with some interesting twists so
when martin asked siri to dance this
time around she accepts willingly would
you want me with a dance
she wouldn't have loved to in contrast
to how originally siri really didn't
want to but kalanthae made her would you
honor me with the dance uh
martin she'd love to the idea here is
that she's just happy to be with her
dead relatives again rather than feeling
like it's an obligation like she did the
first time this fake reality does break
apart a little of course as geralt tries
to reach through to siri and it's only
on for a moment but at one point
malsak's face suddenly flipped to an
image of the doppler assassin who killed
the druid in the first season and took
on his form until revealing his true
nature to siri and dara
the netflix show's first season already
introduced some magical signs that are
popular in the witcher games and we also
get to see some more cool ones in season
two so when geralt is battling the
brooks as piercing screams in the first
episode he casts a quen sign which forms
a defensive shield against the sonic
waves he also appears to cast it later
to create a protective barrier when the
myriapod attacks him in the woods though
this might be the alternate heliotrope
sign which only protects against a
single physical attack and the way
geralt lights up his blade could be
either the igni sign or a temporary fire
rune which he can apply to his sword in
the witcher 2 game and in the final
battle with the deathless mother and the
basilisks geralt casts an urden sign
which can block and slow down monsters
from entering an area protected by the
sign he uses this so he can attempt to
negotiate with voloth and get through to
siri without having to fight the
basilisks at the same time
geralt's mentioned to siri of a
nightmare about an overly friendly rock
troll appears to be an easter egg to the
somewhat chatty trolls in the witcher 3
game can we talk ziggy you like talk me
with there's a big clue you might have
missed a season two's twist ending that
siri's father dooney is still alive but
just before we get to that if you'd like
to try out another immersive gaming
world like the witcher check out
mecharina who've kindly sponsored this
video it's a great low stress
multiplayer combat game where you can
fight with friends or team up with them
in a global arena of other players
there's a fantastic choice of combat
robots you can trick out from bad boy
guardian to speedy kill shot and ninja
like shadow and if you're a fan of
witch's weird and wonderful monsters
you'll like the arachnos a spider tank
you can load up with weapons and which
is a nifty little spider turret you can
drop to do some damage while you take
cover or use for a double attack on an
opponent mech arena also hosts some
amazing contests like the mex are here
event where the winners got to pilot a
real-life mech and which also raised a
hundred thousand dollars for charity
twelve customizable pilots are an
exciting new feature arriving in the
game this month plus there's a packed
schedule of holiday events battle past
season two and new death match maps mech
arena is completely free to play on
android and ios right now so hit my
personal link in the description below
to grab a pack of bonuses including an
exclusive mech heraldic 3 gold crates
plus 50 000 credits
if you watch events in siri's dream
world very closely when she eventually
decides to leave her grandmother mouse
zach and mother all fade away to dust
because in reality they're dead however
notice how her father who's standing
next to pavetta doesn't fade away
because he's actually still alive when
yaskir the bard pops up performing his
latest song in episode 4 he's wearing a
broad brimmed hat with one side pinned
up complete with feathers if the look of
that hat rings a bell it's because
according to the costume designer it's
inspired by the cavalier hat worn by
puss in boots in the shrek franchise
pray for mercy from puss
yaskia's song toss a coin to your witch
it was an instant hit when the series
first debuted but his much angrier
follower bern butcher byrne signals how
he feels about geralt after being
rejected by him in season one and
interestingly to reflect that this time
rather than encouraging his audience to
tip the witcher he's collecting the coin
for himself instead
like the first season the second
season's episode logos are easter eggs
to significant characters and moments in
the show the winged vampire symbol for
the first episode references the brook
sir verena who lives with nivalin the
vines growing out of the wolf's head in
the second episode's logo foreshadow
eskal's fate and how the leshi monster
will end up growing inside him the
swallow in episode 3 represents siri
whose name derives from the elder word
for swallow the sixth episode hand with
fingers that turn into flames is a
reference to the mage reince who can
conjure fire from his bare finger
interestingly the way he gets his facial
burns in the show when jennifer blows
alcohol in his face while he's holding
up a fiery finger is a nod to how she
burned his face in the books by sending
a fire spell through a closing portal
and riance's partner in crime lydia gets
her facial disfigurement after
attempting to blood trace the stolen
vial of siri's elder blood which is a
hat tip to how she was similarly injured
in the books after experimenting on a
mysterious cursed object found in an
acropolis
the final episode's logo of spheres
colliding and smashing into shards which
reform into a tree and not only a
reference to the conjunction of the
spheres but also a hint to the reveal of
a hidden monolith inside the witcher
medallion tree and how siri will split
the tree in two then shatter the stone
to pieces later on in the episode and
there's a clue early in the season of
siri's connection to season two's
monsters when geralt finds that branches
from the lashi and kermoren have entered
siri's room and pulled the shawl of her
dead grandmother kelanthe into the walls
there was a clue to the deathless mother
bringing basilisks into this world when
fringilla talked about the scary story
she heard as a child stories about the
witch in the woods her home perched on
basilisk legs the hut that volthmir was
trapped in did in fact have basilisk
legs and is inspired by slavic legends
of baba yaga a wild mythical witch-like
spirit who lives in the forest and is
said to live in a cabin on chicken legs
there's a lovely tribute to jurassic
park and it's iconic shot of a cup of
rippling water caused by the approach
for t-rex when yaskia freaks out in the
finale at a bowl of moving water as it
means another monster is on its way oh
seriously and this shot of a basilisk
foot as yaskiya hides under the table
right the wrongs well jennifer i don't
see how things could get any wronger
reminds me of the kitchen scene where
the kids hide from the raptors in
spielberg's first dinosaur movie
if you look closely at siri's room at
cair moore and jennifer's room in her
dream where she has a baby with geralt
you'll notice that both places are very
similar including the window door walls
and even position of the bed the reason
for that is that the show's creative
team made a deliberate decision to use
the same set for both siri and yen in
order to foreshadow the close link
between the two women
to reflect the fact that yennefer lost
her power the show's makeup designer
decided to tone down yen's makeup this
season in order to give her character a
less magical more neutral look and it's
just a subtle moment but when jen's
magic does return after she offers
herself as a vessel for volothmir her
purple eyes come back as well
i thought it was curious how siri's
family were dusted avengers infinity war
style especially given that witch's
showrunner lauren schmidt his rig has
said that the wild hunt of the show's
thanos in other words the overarching
big bad of the series and siri herself
is a kind of infinity stone-filled
gauntlet that everyone is now chasing
for her immense powers
netflix's witcher is often compared to
game of thrones and the show itself
sometimes pokes fun at that so in the
opening episode when an ilf guardian
warrior begs for mercy in the aftermath
of the battle of sodom hill gilga
thoughts his reply and his decision to
kill the soldier is a spin on serio
pharrell's game of thrones catchphrase
that the witcher takes and turns on its
head what do we say
to the god of death not today and
coincidentally or not the actor who
played fan favorite tormund giant spain
in game of thrones plays nivalin in that
same episode
when tiseo records the names of the
mages who died at the battle of sodom
hill as well as real witcher characters
from the franchise there are some
made-up ones such as this one here which
is a shout out to witcher showrunner
lauren schmidt his rick a lot of hidden
details much earlier in the season
foreshadowed series big finale and to
discover all the ones you missed tap
here to watch my season 2 ending
explained video plus what to expect in
season 3 including the mysterious
character rhians and lydia are working
for and how siri's father is still alive
so what other easter eggs call backs or
awesome details did you spot this season
and what was your favorite moment
comment below and if you enjoyed this
leave a thumbs up i really appreciate it
and you can tap left for my full
breakdown of the season 2 big finale
thanks for watching and see you next
time yupikai movie lovers